certainly it sounds out of the ordinary
right I'm sure was that Goldman as you
said for seven years although not all of
it was she an undocumented immigrant so
look I think there are kind of two
answers about what happened on the one
hand how she actually got to Goldman is
that she was using fake papers she had a
fake green card and a fake social
security card and you have to read my
story to find out how she got those
things but I think probably the more
important thing and the thing that I
found more interesting while I was
working on the story is that the reason
that I think she probably was undetected
for a lot of time is that she was kind
of just a perfect Goldman Sachs employee
she was incredibly ambitious and she was
incredibly driven and incredibly focused
I mean even with me when I was reporting
the story when I was fact-checking with
her I was gonna say that she can lift
125 pounds behind her back while doing a
certain kind of exercise and she sent me
a video and a person who could confirm
that it was actually 150 why would it
have more you know this is a woman who
really she's a real perfect gold Knight
also interesting point you make in your
article is that people don't necessarily
think that an undocumented immigrant
will be working at a Goldman Sachs
writing that prejudice working for her
in that way I guess I should say right
right so I talked to I think dozens of
people of the story it's cut to two
dozen and one of them was someone who
worked with her and they became friends
and one thing he says in the story that
he said to me was you know I knew she
was from Mexico because julissa I grew
up in a small city called tasco and then
she came to Texas on a tourist visa but
out state it which is why she came
undocumented but he said never would
have occurred to me to think that she
that something was amiss you know
because I think at this level people
just assume that their friends kind of
belong you know they they hang out
they're smart they're impressive I don't
think they really they really questioned
it I what are you doing now I need sort
of political movement in his immigrants
so not to give away the story but the
big thing that happens is she sort of
gets everything she wants
she became wealthy because if Goldman
you're well paid she may lead cuz
Goldman is a remarkable firm and she
also became legal because she got
married but she was also really
unsatisfied and I'm happy so she left
too and she's working now with a
nonprofit called define America